uh for this afternoon is uh by Dimitri
itziksen from Bangor University
talking about read once branching
programs as proof lines
uh this will be um very technically hard
but over your talk
I will talk to him no this is a talk
about proof complexity but for
Simplicity I will talk only about uh my
moment about semantic proof system
and we want to show that it is
unsatisfiable uh the notion of semantic
profession is based on the notion of
proflial for our case proof lion is just
a bullet predicate that is represented
somehow for example for resolution proof
lines or Clauses for cutting planes
proof lines are linear inequalities in
general coefficients over Boolean
variables
if we consider uh inequalities of degree
k
we have some type of system
uh if you consider the junction of
linear equalities over the field
F2 when we get resolution over
characters
in semantic proof system we have uh then
only one
rule from two proflients we can infer
any proflient but when we like if there
is semantic implication
and refutation of a formula is a
sequence of proof lines such that the
last of lines is equivalent to constant
fault function
and every other proof lines either
represent of water for the function of
the formula they are refuted or obtained
by semantic application Rule and two
parameters to the length
and also size of semantic
implementations
for some you know in some cases no
semantic processing is not necessarily
the real proof system in public how
that's because it's not necessarily easy
to verify semantic rule for example for
resolution it is easy 45 for even for
catching planes if we can see the
semantic anti planes it is NP heart in
general case
for thk also hard but for resolution of
authority it's can be done in polynomial
time
okay uh uh the question that I'm
interested is uh how to prove
um uh lower bound just looking on the
type of the proof lions
uh no the easier
observation that if proof lines are too
strong then we can't prove any lower
bounds for example if we choose CNF
formulas as a proof lines then every
anti-disability map has a short
contradiction we just
compute end of all clauses it will be a
CNF formula and this is semantic
refutation
the second
example for example semantic polynomial
calculus is also too strong system
consider for example overreals and free
CNF formula
can refute it as follows we can just
sum of all
I think I'm also presenting Clauses and
sum of square of Boolean axons and these
two
uh polynomials requires a you know
we will get a contradiction
uh
okay uh I know some other result uh
right
noticed that if proof Lions have small
deterministic
communication complexity you know for
example in the model to come
participants at some variables are known
for one participant some other
then in this semantic processing click
coloring is hard formula and for example
it gives lower Bound for resolution and
for cutting planes with
a small case you know with generic
coefficient
can be computed by randomized
communication uh then uh
for example lifted Satan formulas are
hard for three-like refutation
okay
uh
the first observation was that if
proflients are too strong and uh
what is for our other side consider for
example
uh semantic refutation of decision trees
every fruit lion is just a decision tree
not very deep observation that the
resulting proof system is predominantly
equivalent uh to resolution uh
let's understand why no this is
the one semantic
step
and it is easy to show that CNF
representation of
conclusion can be derived from CNF
representation of premises
in resolution
to see this you know
every
this decision trick how to how to
construct a CNF we just can consider
zero leaves and consider Clauses that
are refuted in this zero leaves and
consider for example one zero leaf and
cost responding to it and
write this path
separately and in standard Leaf we have
the first decision training after it we
delete
non-consistent parts
and here it is still possible that
here we have zero and here we also that
we have one and for all ones we hang the
second
decision three
and here I claim that uh we it is also
possible that the there are some such
some ones but all of them belongs to
inconsistent paths if we delete all
inconsistent parts we
well if something like this and this is
just a decision tree and in this point
the clause what we consider is refuted
so this is the like refutation
this Clause from
the size of this refutation
connected with the size of this decision
please
for example this the same also false if
we consider semantic calculus of uh
parity decision three when we will get
resolution of our pilities by this by
the same reason
okay
uh uh for this for decision three we
have a very uh small simple
proof system that for Freight we have
lower bound but if we consider instead
of decision three for example uh or
Advanced branching program
and uh this uh origin is not work
because uh
uh each Leaf will correspond to many
Clauses and uh
we don't have we will not yet
resolution refutation let's continue
let's define the branching problems and
what red one virtual problem this is a
little flower goal this is Branch
program is a way to represent a Boolean
function uh it's represented by direct
classical graph every vertex is labeled
by variable and to edges outgoing
labeled by zero labeled by one and we
have two things zero sinks and one sink
and uh to compute the value We Go From
the Source
according the value of variables and
finally onto the sync this is a value of
the function
uh there are one very important partial
case of with one branching program that
you usually used in practice and
distance software
[Music]
Hardware verification is ordered binary
diagram it's a partial case of read one
branching program then all variables on
all paths appears in the same order
there are one order of variables and no
no bars
why it is important because
representation of many important
functions for example Clauses uh
priorities oh for example this is what
is this function is parity and also
linear inequalities with small
coefficients can be represented by small
obdd and what is more important than the
binary operation for BDS if two or BG
have the same order can be performed
very efficiently in linear time
actually uh
uh
and uh no these properties I used for
upper bounds the lower bounds is also
will be
necessarily form of property of ability
for us that if you partition variables
to two parts uh that agree with the
order
then the communication complexity of
computing ability uh is a logarithm for
fifth size uh because uh first of all
first participants
go from The Source
by his variables and after it you just
send the number of vertex and the second
participant in the computer result
okay and uh
I I I will discuss in this talk
the semantic proof system where read
one's branching programs are proof lines
but we start with OBD proofs
the proof system was defined by
serious colitis and margin
and uh
uh you know formally uh derivation we
choose a variable order of variables for
all the bdds
uh
and we Define the following groups first
rule is conjunction rule for two
Mobility we can infer the conjunctions
the second rule is weakening rule
uh we can derive any OBD that
semantically implied from
no we didn't
and in that paper there also defined
projection rule that is in fact a
partial case of weakening rule uh that's
for OBD we can derive with the exists x
d the x is some variable
why it is interest more interesting
because
it looks more practical because we can
rule there are a lot of ways how to
begin but not too many rules how to
apply projection rule at most number of
variables
okay uh and uh
uh no the the the the the goal here is a
to drive a constant false OBD using
these rules if we consider only first
rule we uh
will get uh just semantic
of system uh with one restriction that
all of the disease have the same order
uh
but uh this restriction looks maybe
rather
artificial and it is possible to add the
reordering rule that we can just
Drive the same function but written in
the other order all these rules uh can
be efficiently verified using the
properties of bdg
and uh there are a lot of proof system
defined by this definition we just we
can use the different set of rules
and we put them in the brackets
and uh
uh consider some partial case of them
for example we have only conjunction and
projection rule
this proof system uh is rather
interesting for example it can solve a
system of linear equations and such as
Fable look I can review it because uh if
we have we take two
linear equations and can see the
conjunction and projection or the common
variable we will get just the sum of
this equation
and also this profession simulate
resolution because resolution rule is
also just conjunction of two Clauses and
within the projection rule
and it is known that there is a short
proof of polynomial
of pigeon for principle
okay and open question whether with
proof system simulates cutting plans
with
generic efficiency why with unary
because
short representation of equalities with
unary coefficient not necessary in
arbitrary case
okay uh uh uh their proof system
obviously and the weakening uh because
no this is just a semantic proof system
and since OBD can represent linear
equations uh then it's trivial that this
proof system simulates
that implants resume the coefficients
it turns out that uh there are short
proof of Click coloring principle in
this proof system and it was even noted
by itself as quite similarity that there
is such order of variables such that if
we consider refutation
where used on all of these all over
these use this particular order then
uh uh any proof of click on has
exponential size so we have one easier
order where there is polynomial
and we have another order that it's hard
and uh
this hard order was used by kratchex to
prove lower bound uh for all orders uh
uh the idea was falling she devised a
transformation uh what I assume that Phi
is a Formula at heart for one particular
order by right device transformation
that uh whereas
sketchy likes as follows
she had the variables that encodes a
permutation permutation of variables and
uh part of the formula says that Sigma
includes the permutation and after it we
add the formula Phi with variables
permuted
by Sigma
and since uh assume that this formula
has a short refutation in some order but
we know that there is a
hard order and we substitute uh this
hard order to Sigma and that's why we
get a
reputation of fee if the handsets should
be exponential size
uh very nice extension of this approach
was proposed by segerlin
also defines transformation with the
same property but it's my has some
additional uh important properties uh
first of all simply consider
verification of initial formula just any
variables substituted by or of many
other variables
and he considered
since we make this verification it is
possible to consider not all permutation
but only uh some small number of
permutations from uh the set of two
independent permutations at and using
this nice property
it is possible to separate
this procedure from other for example uh
to prove that this processing does not
simulate result or as for Flow game
and using these two orders that in one
order polycar link is simple in other
ordering a heart
it's possible to prove that reordering
adding reordering make a Pro System
harder
uh
we just considered civilian
transformation
applied to click coloring
and it will be harsh here but uh it
since we have a small number of uh
rotations here we can we can just uh
we can just use the simple order always
reorder this part for simple order and
finally we have short
yes so just
um the second and third result both of
them are fixed orders but in the second
result it's a different ordering or do
you allow
one border for all
okay
so
sorry but no yes
project four one this is harder
also if you have another ordering or not
it's rather complicated
[Music]
I think that
it's not open but nobody tries
[Music]
coloring goes through physical
interpolation
so
[Music]
okay and this is uh the whole picture
what we know and here one good system
simulates other if there is a path with
both and if not there is no part that
there is no simulation and if there is a
path that use
uh dotted age then the existing of
simulation is open question
for example it is interesting that uh
star does not simulate just if we have
only conjunction rule
uh
and all also weakening rule can't
simulate reordering through
okay
it's also can be shown that it is in the
heart to automate uh
OBD with end and weakening
there is a following theorem that there
is a predominal Time function letting
CNF to cnfs
with the following property uh if fee is
satisfiable Formula then the result of
this function has a short resolution
reputation and if V is undispable
Formula then
any of the and weekend reputation has
exponential size now the proof strategy
the the corollary that it is in the
heart of the mileage the proof strategy
um is more or less standard and follows
Terrace Miller paper and first of all we
prove uh this transformation for one
particular variable order
and after it we apply secure line
transformation
and how to prove for particular this is
uh similar to the automatability of
cutting players
by this paper it is proved by lifting
from resolution block widths to dig like
communication
protocols with many participants but not
too many as was in case of
cutting plans in the number
in the health model but I think they
have no time to
development
okay and what about uh where I speak
only about obviously what about the
advanced branching program okay of
course if you consider semantic
reputation of reverberating program uh
that this will be harder this will be
stronger than this proof system and for
this Pro System we don't know
any lower bounds
uh
uh well this system is uh non no it's a
semantic system it's not critical for
example it has short refutation for
formula based on bipartite graphs for
example pigeonhole prints about setting
formulas and paper file drafts and and
so on uh just the the certification we
[Music]
um
first of all consider and of all
conditions from one part of the graph
and it has a small ability
representation for uh convenient order
and then for the second part in the
another order and just one end and we
will get a prediction
but it is possible to prove exponential
lower bound
and the hard formulas are perfect
matching formulas uh that the following
the variables corresponds to
ages and we put down the condition that
every vertex is covered and the every
vertex is covered twice
and the following serum holds that if
there is good enough expander then
Perfection and Satan based on gravity uh
require
uh such proof of exponential sites
uh the proof idea is the following uh
for perfect matching uh we consider only
closes of this size this is the main
Clauses and we can we can find the first
moment when we download
uh
the quite many of such Clauses and it is
not important for us how many such
causes we have
and it is possible to show that in this
all such function has large Revival
branching program representation
actually this proof uh holds not only
for advanced Branch problem but also for
non-deterministic advanced branching
problem uh in the domestic bench
performance such vertices can be maxed
by or instead of a variable it means
that we can go to either direction and
we accept if there is path to one thing
and uh it is interesting that uh this
for this proof system extension rule
can't help
because of all extension variables we
can change to this or node
and if we consider lower bound and we
can also always can end several
extensions such that the results
informally will be easy to treat like
resolution
and the corollary that uh even if we
consider Advanced non-perministic main
problem with and this proof system will
not simulate tree like resolution
also this result implies uh the special
outer bounds if we admit small number of
projection as a linear but small
question just
for deciding formulas but then you said
you you only required okay
okay so non white extenders yes
algebraic exposure expanders
okay and in that I will say some words
about uh probability based that
algorithms
the goal is to just to solve success
somebody is a problem and consider
following I've got it from that has obdd
in some order initially it's constant
one it can download Clauses from formula
and when we download plus then it delete
from the formula and it also can apply
projection rule
if variable X does not appear
in the formula it was also deleted then
we can apply projection rule
and also we add reordering role that we
can
reorder our lobby to any or the whatever
you like
uh and finally when all clothes are
download we just report whether OBD we
have a satisfiable or not
and a running time of this is polynomial
connected with the size of the largest
OBD that we have during the execution
and a little derivation was first
defined by aguir and varde
and uh it is known that Satan formulas
are easy for such kind of algorithms no
this is not one algorithm we can apply
rules in different using different
strategy also uh
digital principle and if we not use a
reordering rule then a lower bounds
implies from lower bound from OBD Pro
system
what but what if we can use learning Pro
uh it's even possible to prove a lower
Bound for the case when we have good
ones deterministic batch program instead
of obdities
and how this lower bound works first of
all we prove lower Bound for satisfiable
formulas and they looks as follows we
can see the special linear quote and the
hard formula encodes that acts as
according words
and uh but this is satisfiable formula
and how to construct hard unsatisfiable
formula
the weak points of this algorithm that
to apply when it applies projection rule
it should download all clauses that
contains variables maybe it's two to too
many Clauses and her formulas I use the
following idea there is drawdog either
we do not use projection rule at all
uh
uh or we have to solve hard
formula for this Pro system
and this also implies this hard example
that such algorithms do not simulate to
like
resolution and my student proof no this
holds for this proof system but the
formula is very artificial and my
students proved lower Bound for uh
formula with clear meaning for Bitcoin
principle
but here we have obtuse system
okay and several open question
uh uh first of all uh for me I think
it's interesting to prove lower bound
here uh for some natural formula and the
natural candidate is binary pigeonhole
principle
uh also it is interesting to separate uh
we can grow and projection rule
uh no the main questions prove lower
Bound for this or more interesting for
just for semantic calculus of reverse
branching program
uh there are a lot several questions uh
considered very simple proof system OBD
will just end it's very simple but many
things not understandable first of all
is it true that uh bounded Frankie can
simulate this proof system or resolution
can quasially normally simulate it to
separate deck like and pre-like version
uh to prove that that it is open for
this procession that random formulas are
hard
uh it's can also be interesting to prove
uh
polynomial bound if we
just end and but yet to be and it's also
open whether this
simple proof system is automatable or
not
okay thank you for attention sorry
thank you to uh had some questions and
uh do we have some questions for Dmitry
um
[Music]
bridgeports I'm not a proof Lions
it's something like IPS but instead of
polynomials you can see your Venture
program
I've already mentioned uh
probably the East and he went very
quickly and I was like what he said
you cannot automatize
[Music]
huh
um
yes resolution and the lower bound is
OBD so you cannot automate advertise OBD
and OB
vious resolution
yes
okay I have a great question so back in
the 90s when people were doing a lot of
uh you know model checking and so on
with obdds before sat solvers kind of
came in one of the things they would do
was partition obdds and talk about the
representation of what's rather than a
single monolithic OBD was as a
conjunction of some number of obdds how
does that
is is it possible to compare that with
these
uh models uh not as
incorrectly most full lies here okay it
does it does actually like that okay
questions
yeah there is this model that I can not
even Define it out of my head is
there are different numbers of Deeds
this conjunction
the proof is almost the same
but they're probably stronger than
obviously but they're related with one
branch program they are stronger than
when one expansion program but in that
paper they considered something
instead of order in that model there as
a tree
right you know so so they're different
versions of of their of these there's
the decision version which is like a one
one BP except you have conjunction nodes
that's one version and then there's
structured uh DNA where where you've got
the B tree or something like that and so
yeah
generalization of what we do use that
way and we're
sentential decision decision diagrams or
some special piece of Roads as well so I
mean like if this I have several of the
problem in OBD in this regard it will be
even more difficult
another question okay
[Applause]